hey welcome to draft Academy my name is
Mike in this course I'm gonna teach you
everything that you need to know to get
started using Gatsby j/s Gatsby j/s is a
relatively new static site generator
that's built on top of nodejs and it
uses react in order to help you build an
awesome fast and scalable of static
website one of the things I love about
Gatsby is that you build your static
sites using react and so you have all
the power
modularity and scalability of react
while still being able to generate
static web pages which can be served
extremely fast on your web server so you
write all of your pages and react you
can access data and you can make your
pages interactive and do all sorts of
cool things and then you just generate a
bunch of static pages and serve them up
on your web server in this course we're
gonna talk about the basics so we're
gonna get into installing gatsby
building your first gatsby site fleshing
out all the pages on your site and then
we're gonna get a little more advanced
so we're going to talk about making your
pages interactive and we're gonna look
at how you can use graph QL in order to
access different types of data about
your site so we're going to be able to
access metadata about the site we'll be
able to access information about the
different files and we'll also be able
to parse through markdown files on our
site and display them in an awesome way
so if you're looking for a static site
generator you might want to consider
using Gatsby not only is it backed by
the awesome power of react but it's also
a new project which means it's
constantly being added to and developed
Gatsby's not going anywhere and
therefore you can feel safe investing
some of your web infrastructure in it
check out this draft Academy course
we're gonna give you everything you need
to know to get started and I'm excited
to see what you guys learn
in this tutorial I'm gonna show you
everything that you need to do to get
Gatsby up and running on your computer
and one of the cool things about Gatsby
is the way you install it on Windows and
Mac is actually the same so Gatsby
relies on this program called nodejs so
all we have to do is install nodejs
on your windows or our mac computer and
then using nodejs and something called
the node package manager we can install
Gatsby and get it up and running and
ready to go so if you already have no
js' and the node package manager
installed on your computer then all you
have to do is just skip to the end of
the video and you'll see the part where
I actually install Gatsby but if you
don't have no js' installed in your
computer I'm gonna show you exactly how
to do that right now so all you want to
do is go over to this website here it's
no js' org
/en forward slash download and there's
three options here that we can click for
our download windows mac or the source
code so you just want to pick whichever
operating your says whichever operating
system you're on I'm on Mac so I'm just
gonna click Mac and once that's
downloaded I'm just gonna go over to my
downloads folder and I'm just gonna
double click on this and what they
should do is open up this nodejs
installer so all we want to do here is
just click continue and accept anything
we need to accept and then we can
install nodejs on our computer so once
that's done installing we want to check
and just make sure that everything is
installed correctly so I'm gonna open up
a terminal and I just want to type in
the following code we're just gonna type
node - - version and that should spit
out a version and then we can also type
NPM - - version and that should spit out
another version so we're using nodejs
and then in order to install gath we're
going to use NPM which is the node
package manager and that's basically
just a program that we can use to
install other programs so we're going to
use it to install Gatsby so once you
validated that node is installed
correctly on your computer we just have
to use this node
manager to install it so I'm just gonna
type NPM install - - global and then I
just want to type Gatsby - CLI and that
just stands for Gatsby command-line
interface so this is how we're gonna
communicate with Gatsby we're gonna use
this command line interface we'll be
able to give Gatsby commands and tell it
to do different things for us so I'm
gonna click enter and this should go off
and start installing everything that we
need for Gatsby and you can see here
that it installed everything we needed
and it's just a bunch of different files
so in order to just validate that
everything is installed correctly we can
just type Gatsby - - version and this
should spit out a version of Gatsby so
as long as you can get that version to
come out like this then Gatsby is
officially installed on your computer
and you're ready to start building your
first Gatsby website
in this tutorial we're going to talk
about creating your first Gatsby site so
we're gonna create our Gatsby site and
then we're gonna look at some of the
default folders and files that gatsby
creates for us when we make that new
site and then we're gonna serve our site
onto the internet and we'll be able to
see our site running on our local server
so let's get started this is gonna be an
awesome tutorial first thing I want to
do to create my Gatsby site is open up a
new terminal window in my case I just
have one down here in my text editor and
in order to create our Gatsby site we
need to enter in some commands into this
terminal so I just want to type Gatsby
new and now I want to type in the name
of the website that I want to create so
this will be like the name of your
Gatsby site my case would just do GA
underscore site for draft County site
and now what we want to do is enter in
the address of a project template that
we can use so gatsby actually has a sort
of like a hello world introductory
project set up on github and all we have
to do to access that is just type in
this URL so it's github comm forward
slash gatsby j s forward slash catsby
starter hello world so just enter this
in after that Gatsby nuke yeah that gets
me new command and will be able to get
that gatsby starter project that we can
use and that's what I'm gonna be using
in this tutorial so we're gonna click
enter and Gatsby should go out and
basically go out to github get that
project template and then start
installing it onto our machine so this
could take anywhere from like one to
three minutes it really just depends but
it's probably not gonna be like super
fast so that's done installing and for
me it took about a minute for that to
install everything that it needed to
install and once that's done we come up
here into our File Explorer you'll
notice that I have this new folder that
was created inside My Documents folder
called GA site so this is the folder
that got to be created for our project
so I'm just gonna open this up and I
want to sort of talk you through what
all of these did
things are inside of here it might be a
little intimidating if you haven't
worked with something that looks like
this before I do that though I just want
to show you how we can actually build
our site and see it online so the way
that we can do that is by coming back
down here into our terminal and I want
to type the following commands I'm well
first off I just want to change
directory into that new site and then I
want to type NPM run develop and what
this is going to do is it's going to
start up a Gatsby development server on
our localhost that we can test our
website out and it's sort of use it to
develop so this is like mostly what
you're going to be using when you're
testing your site so that's finished
running and you'll see that we get all
these success messages I do just want to
point out some of the stuff down here
you'll notice that this site is running
at localhost 8000
is like a local web server that's on
your computer so if we go over to
localhost 8080
logo has 8,000 is now hosting our site
it's a really simple site it just says
hello world so this isn't like anything
crazy but this is actually our site
running and so any changes that we make
to our site will show up here on this
development server as long as that
server is running to back over in the
text editor again I just want to talk
you guys through sort of the default
files that you'll see now there are a
couple things in here related to node J
s and one of those things is this node
modules folder and you'll notice if you
click down in this folder there's like a
bunch of other folders inside of here
this is just something that's used for
nodejs you're really not gonna have to
worry about this too much now you're
gonna need it so you don't want to
delete it but you know as far as like
having to modify anything in there you
probably most likely won't have to next
we have this public folder and you'll
notice that there's really not too much
stuff here in this public folder and
this public folder is basically the
folder that represents like your
finished
static website so you'll see later in
this course we can build our website
which means we can compile all of the
gatsby pages that we write together into
our finished static site that we can set
that we can then serve on to the web and
all of your like static web pages and
your finished
static site is gonna go inside of this
public folder so this is basically just
what our site would look like now and we
can put these files on a web server and
it would be our site the next folder is
probably the most important folder and
it's the folder that you're gonna be
using the most it's this source folder
and this is where we're going to store
all of the pages for our website so if
you're building like a blog site you'd
store all of your blog pages in here if
we build a normal website again all your
pages are gonna go in here and you'll
see we have this pages folder by default
and then we have this index dot JSP now
because gatsby is built on nodejs and
more specifically gatsby uses react j/s
all of our files are actually just going
to be JavaScript files so the content
files that we write and a lot of like
the files will be right for our
components are going to be JavaScript
you can also use other formats like
markdown and stuff like that too but for
now in this default structure we just
have this pages folder and then we have
this index dot JSP
so really the source folder like I said
is is the most important folder and it's
gonna it's gonna be where you're
spending most of your time there's also
some other files down here this dot get
ignore file this is just a file that's
used with git and then we have these
package JSON files and this is another
file that's used with nodejs and there
will be a couple instances where we're
gonna have to modify this but for the
most part the package JSON file
basically just manages all the
dependencies and all sort of like the
overall settings of your nodejs
app which is what we have right here so
package j/s package JSON file is
important but for like the normal use
cases you probably won't have to touch
it that much so like I said for the most
part this source folder is going to be
really important that's a basic overview
of the folder structure in Gatsby and we
also got our site up and running on
localhost so now you're ready to go out
and start adding content to your site
and really start digging deep into
Gatsby
in this tutorial we're going to talk
about adding content to your Gatsby
files so basically we're just gonna take
that default index file that Gatsby
gives us and we're gonna add in some
different HTML element so we're gonna
talk about how you can start building
your pages so over here I just have this
basic gatsby default layout and inside
the source folder in pages we have this
index dot JSP and if you look over here
on my website I'm actually viewing this
index file so this index dot JSP Lizz
like the root directory it's like the
home page of our website and you'll see
in here that there's a bunch of react
code actually it's JavaScript but it's
using react and so if this doesn't look
super familiar to you it's actually
basically just using this framework
called react j/s and you don't need to
know too much about react to use gatsby
but it does help to be like a little bit
familiar with it but for now just know
that like all this fancy code over here
is JavaScript and it's for this react
framework you can see here is we have a
bunch of stuff that looks like HTML and
and it's very similar to HTML and it
works the same way so we just have this
div and then inside of it we have hello
world and what's cool is that by default
gatsby is a hot reloading framework so
if I make a change over here to this div
it'll automatically get updated over
here on our website so I could say like
hello world it's me and when I save this
page it automatically gets updated so
without me having to refresh the browser
it will automatically save over here so
kind of makes it really easy for you to
develop your site you know it really
makes a development cycle a lot quicker
you don't have to like go over and
physically refresh the page every time
whenever you make a change it's just
automatically appearing over here so
that's just like a little thing that
makes gatsby pretty cool
an addition to having like for example a
div we could also have other HTML
elements so I could put like a header in
here right we could say like here's a
header
and then I can have maybe like a
paragraph as well and when that loads up
you'll see it loads up just like normal
HTML now one thing that you need to keep
in mind when you're writing content
inside of these files as you can't have
two HTML elements that are at the same
level so if I was to come over here and
create a paragraph and I created this
paragraph at the same level of this div
so I either like what are called sibling
elements when I save the page you'll
notice that I get an error and that's
because it says you have a jason JSX
elements and so really although this
looks like we're writing in HTML we're
actually writing in a special javascript
HTML like hybrid language called JSX and
it's basically like a way that you can
write HTML inside of a javascript file
but one of the rules is that you can't
have two sibling elements just like this
so everything has to be wrapped inside
of like a single element like if I put
this inside of this div then this error
should go away and it should just show
up so that's just something to keep in
mind when you're writing content inside
of something like this and inside of
this JSX we can also make some styling
so I could like style this div and the
way that we would style this would we be
style and then equals and then inside
these double curly brackets we can put
some CSS so I could say like color and I
could do a colon and then I need to put
this inside of quotation marks but I
could say like blue and now this will
change all of the text to blue or I
could change it to tomato and it would
change it to tomato so you can use CSS
sort of inline just like this and if I
wanted to add for example like another
attribute here so I could say like
background color we could set this equal
to blue
and it'll set the background to blue so
you can add in different CSS stylings
inside of these JSX elements just very
similar to how you would an HTML if you
if you're familiar with CSS then you'll
notice that this is a little bit
different but the same concepts apply
another thing we could do would be link
to an image so I could say like IMG and
I just have this image of this cute cat
because we're on the Internet so I'll
paste this in here and then we can just
close off this image tag and now this
image should show up in our website so
yeah there's the image of the cat it's
like way too big but you can see that it
shows up nonetheless so that's kind of
like the basics of you know adding in
content into these JavaScript files and
you can see that it's actually pretty
easy and it's very similar to just
writing normal HTML and so if you're not
familiar with JSX and how that works and
how it kind of is used and react then
you might want to look that up but for
the most part you know as long as you're
just writing normal HTML you're pretty
much safe and it's probably gonna work
like 90% of the time but yeah so that's
kind of the basics of adding content to
these files and any of these j/s files
that we store over here in this pages
folder you can basically do this with so
you can just put all your sort of HTML
text and HTML tags over here and it will
just display on the website normally
in this tutorial we're going to talk
about linking between the pages on our
website in Gatsby so up to this point in
the tutorial we just have this one page
which is index.jsp good website you're
gonna have more than one page so
eventually you're gonna want to be able
to link between the different pages on
your website so I'm going to show you
exactly how to do that the first thing
we want to do if we're gonna link
between pages on our site is we want to
go up here and we want to add in another
import statement so I'm just gonna say
import and instead of saying react we'll
say link from and then inside of
quotation marks we're just gonna type
Gatsby - link what this is gonna do is
it's gonna allow us to use a react
component and that react component is
called link and basically all you need
to know is that we can use the link
component or the link tag in order to
create a link between the pages on our
site so I want to come down here into
this HTML and I'm just gonna use this
link tag so now that we imported it we
can use a tag called link and then I'm
gonna say link to and then I knew I want
to type the address of the page that I
want to link to if you're familiar with
normal HTML then you'll know about the
like a normal link which is just the a
tag and normally we would just type like
a and then href and then inside of here
we would put the path of the page that
we wanted to visit but since this is
God's P and since we're using react we
have to do it this way so we can use
this link and then inside here I'm just
gonna put this whole link to like page
two and then I can put some text in here
so we'll say like page two and then we
can close off this link just like that
so what this will do is create a link to
page two on our website so now if I head
over here you'll see that we have this
link and when I click this link you'll
notice that we get this development 404
page so basically a 404 page not found
right this page isn't on our website and
that's kind of a problem so
come over here into this pages folder
and we'll make a new file and I'm just
gonna call it page - 2 . j s so this is
gonna be another javascript file and I
wanna just actually I'm just gonna go
back here we don't get this red screen
of death I want to come over here to
this index and I'm just gonna copy all
of the code from in here and I'll just
paste the end of this new page that way
we don't have to write it out we can
just have it and I'm just gonna get rid
of some of this stuff and on this new
page we'll just say that this is page 2
and so now our link should actually work
so when I click this page to link it'll
bring me to this page on our website you
can see that it does another thing we
could do would be create another link on
this page and we'll link back to the
home page so I'm gonna copy the link
that we have over here and I'll bring it
here into page two and now instead of
linking to page 2 we can just link to
the home page which is just a forward
slash and we can say go home so now we
have this go home link and we can link
back to the home page so these links are
now operational and we can link between
the pages on our site so you can see I
mean if you created like a bunch of
different pages on your site then you
could create the links for them another
thing I want to point out is we can also
put pages inside of sub directories so
if I created a folder let's call this
folder
Derwin and inside of Derwin we'll make a
new file and we'll just call it page - 3
and that's gonna be another javascript
file and again I'm just gonna copy this
code and we'll put it inside of page 3
and so from the home page now we can
also in addition to linking to page 2 we
can link to page 3 except now when we
put our path we're gonna want to put
dyrone forward slash page 3
and this should link us to page three so
you know organizing your content inside
of this pages directory is something
that you want to you know actually do
and really the pages directory is kind
of like the root directory of your web
server and so you know index dot JSP h2
or both at the root directory right and
then page three is inside of this
subdirectory dyrone so you really want
to pay attention to how you're ordering
your content and that's kind of how you
can do it in Gatsby
in this tutorial we're gonna talk about
making your Gatsby pages interactive one
of the cool things about Gatsby is it's
built using this framework called react
Jas and react Jas was built by Facebook
and so you know it's like a powerhouse
framework one of the cool things about
react is that it allows us to make our
websites really interactive so the user
can actually like interact with the
website and the website will respond to
the user and I'm gonna show you how we
can build a page that just implements
like a simple little counter so you'll
press like a plus button and the counter
will increment and then you'll plus
you'll press a minus button and the
counter will decrement so the first
thing I want to do is come over here
into this pages folder and I'm going to
create a new file we're just gonna call
this counter Jas so inside of this
counter file we are going to make our
counter and then in our index file I
just want to create a link so that we
can easily get to this counter page and
so this will just link us to the counter
so actually I'm gonna put a break in
here so now when we click this link
it'll bring us over to our counter page
now there is some like default code that
I want to put inside this counter Jas
file and I'm just gonna paste it in and
then I'm gonna explain what the code is
doing and then you can just copy it in
on your own and that way you can
practice kind of like writing this stuff
out so you'll notice I just pasted it in
a bunch of code and this code actually
looks a little bit different than the
code that we had in our index j s5
that's because this code is different so
again this is just JavaScript code and
it's code that's for the react framework
and I'll just kind of walk you through
what's in here so up here we're just
importing react and now we're creating a
class called counter and it's extending
the react dot component so basically
this is going to be a react component
which is basically just like a little
component inside a react that can do
certain things so and then we have this
render function right here and basically
anything that goes inside of the
render function is going to get
displayed on the page and so here we're
returning all of the stuff that's going
to get displayed so we're just returning
whatever is in here and so inside of
this class we can put a bunch of code
that's gonna help to make our react
component dynamic so it'll help to make
our page dynamic and so now on this
counter page we just have basically just
a div that says that it's the class
component and now I want to start adding
in some code so the first thing I'm
gonna do is add in some HTML elements
and this will kind of like be the setup
for our counter so inside of these divs
I'm just gonna paste in this code and
you'll notice here we have a bunch of
code so we have a header that says
counter we have a paragraph that says
the current count which is zero and then
we have two buttons a plus button and a
minus button so eventually what we want
to happen is when the user clicks this
plus button we want this counter to
increment and when the user clicks this
minus button we want the counter to
decrement so over here on our page we
just have the plus and the minus buttons
and you'll notice that nothing happens
right now but all we have to do is just
add in a little bit of logic into this
react class into this Gatsby class and
it'll start working so the first thing
I'm going to do is add in what's called
a constructor so up here I'm just gonna
paste in some more code so it's gonna
look like this and actually this isn't
formatted very well but this is a
constructor function and so basically
what this is doing is that this gets
called whenever we create this class or
whatever we like reload the page and
it's setting this variable called state
and so state is a variable that
basically represents the state of the
component and I'm not gonna get too much
into what State does but for all you
need to know for now is just that inside
of this state variable we can store a
variable called count so basically we
can store the current
inside of this state object so we can
store the camera right there and then I
also want to add in some other code and
it's actually going to go in the counter
and so I'm just gonna put this right
here
and you'll notice that now instead of
just having a zero here when we're
trying to access the current count we
have something that says this dot state
dot count what this is doing is its
accessing this state variable up here so
basically instead of just displaying
zero we want to display the value of the
count inside of the state and then
there's one more thing we need to do
which is get the buttons working right
in other words we want something to
happen when we click the buttons because
right now when we click these buttons
nothing happens right if I click the
plus button and the minus button the
count just stays where it is so what we
need to do is add in a little function
in here to this button tag and again I'm
just gonna paste it in and then I'll
show you what it's doing so what it
looks like here is we have button and
then it says on click equals and then we
have these open curly brackets and then
two parentheses and what we're doing
here is we're setting the state so it
says this dot set state and then inside
of here it just says count and so
basically what this is doing is it's
decrementing the counter right so it's
subtracting one from the counter and
actually I think I could probably format
this a little bit better so you guys can
see it right so this is basically just
what its gonna look like right here and
actually this should be the minus button
because we're decrementing so then I can
take this same type of code and use it
for the plus button but instead of
decrementing it so instead of
subtracting one over here we can just
add one so I'm gonna do the same thing
and I'm just gonna paste it in here and
so now when i refresh this page what
should happen is when I click the minus
button the current cow should decrement
when I click the plus button the current
cow should
and you'll see I'm clicking the plus
button and the counter is incremented
and I'm clicking the minus button and
it's decrementing so that's kind of how
you can make your pages dynamic and so
basically I'm just using this on click
function down here and it's setting the
state variable which we set up here in
the constructor and it's either
incrementing that count or it's
decrementing that count and now it's
kind of how yeah that's one way that you
can make your pages interactive
obviously the more you learn about react
j/s the more you'll be able to use these
react components to make your website
more interactive and more dynamic
in this tutorial I'm gonna show you how
you can build your Gatsby website so
let's say that you have a bunch of
different files and folders and
resources on your website and now you
want to serve it up on a web server
right well how can we access all of
those files in other words up until now
we've been testing our website on this
localhost development server but what
happens when you want to take those
files and put them up on a server of
your own well we can actually use a
build command in order to build our
Gatsby website and so basically we can
execute a certain command and then
Gatsby will go out and build all of our
pages together into static pages that we
can then copy and paste or FTP or
whatever over onto our web server so I'm
just gonna show you how to do that
really quick so I just want to CD into
my directory and once I'm inside of my
project directory I can run a simple
command which is just NPM run build and
basically this is just gonna tell gatsby
like hey we want to build our site so
I'm gonna click enter and this is gonna
go off and do a bunch of stuff it's
gonna build up our entire website so
once that's done building I want to head
over to my file tree and you'll see here
we have this folder called public and
this is where gatsby spit out all of our
static files so inside of this public
folder i'm just gonna open it up and
you'll notice that there's a bunch of
files and there's a bunch of like
javascript files in here and stuff like
that but basically this is our entire
site so there's actually a lot of these
different files and that's kind of what
its gonna be like but you'll also notice
up here we have like directory 1 and
then there's this page 3 and page 2 and
there's this static folder and this
counter folder so this is actually all
of the resources that we need to include
on our web server if we want to run our
site so all I would have to do would be
like copy and paste this stuff onto my
web server and it would start working or
you could serve up all of this stuff
using like some sort of a deployment app
like natla fire or something like that
but basically all you need to know is
that this public folder has all the
files that you need for your
so anytime that you make a change to
your website and you want to regenerate
the files you can actually just run that
npm run build command again and it'll
build all these files and it'll sort of
like over I overwrite the public folder
and do everything that you need it to do
inside of there
in this tutorial I'm just gonna give you
a quick overview of using components in
react now I could make an entire course
just talking about using components in
react and if you're not familiar with
how react works and how components work
then this will just kind of give you a
brief overview of how these components
work and really just sort of help you to
wrap your mind around what we're doing
here so a component in a react is
basically just a collection of JSX or a
collection of HTML that has maybe some
styling maybe some logic and it sort of
contained in this one class or this one
container and what we can do then is
import that into other files on our
website and sort of use it and the best
way for me to explain this is just to
kind of show you so earlier in this
tutorial we created this counter j/s
class and if I go over here my website I
can click and you'll see this is the
counter and basically all it does is
just increments and decrements a counter
when you click these buttons now this is
what's called a react component and so
you'll notice that the whole component
is just this thing right here and it has
some some of this JSX some of this HTML
style stuff in here right and then it
also has this constructor function up
here and it has these functions like
this on click function inside of this
button so there's a lot going on inside
of this component now imagine that I
wanted to take this counter and I wanted
to insert it on another page in my
website right so here on the home page
how about instead of just linking to
counter so instead of just having this
counter link imagine I wanted to
actually physically put the counter on
the page well the way that we can do
that is by inserting our component or
including our component inside of our
index file and I'll show you how we can
do that first thing we want to do is
come up here and I'm just going to type
import and then I want to type the name
of the react component that I want to
import so in our case it's gonna be
counter and then I'm gonna say from and
here we just want to put the path to the
file and this is going to be the path of
the file starting at the
directory of our website so it's gonna
be dot slash and then it's just called
counter dot J s and actually I don't
think we need the Jas
so we've imported this counter and now
we can actually use it so I can come
down here in my JSX and let's say that
instead of just linking we want to now
actually include the counter so I'll get
rid of this and I'm gonna add in this
counter tag so this is the name of the
component so we're gonna refer to it
just like this and then I can just do a
forward slash and we'll close off this
tag and so now when we save this page
the counter shows up over here and so
instead of just having that counter on
its own page right so if we go over to
this counter page the counters here but
now we can just include that counter on
our own page and that's basically how
you're gonna be building your pages
using in in Gatsby right you want to be
using these components and it takes a
little while to kind of get used to
using these components but it's a really
great way to develop and that's
basically the whole point of react is to
break up your website into these
different components now there's another
thing that you can do with these react
components and you can actually pass
them information so in here I could pass
this counter for example like a color so
I could say color is equal to and we'll
just pass in blue and I can actually
access this color variable from inside
my component so I'm here in my counter
component and if I wanted to access the
color I could basically just type out
something like this so I can do open and
closed curly brackets and then I can
type this dot props and then I want to
type the name of the variable that we
passed in so it's just gonna be color in
our case and this will print out the
color so over here you can see it's
printing out blue and I can actually use
this color to style this component so I
can come up here to this div and we can
make a style and then inside these style
tags I could say color and I could set
it equal to
this stop props color so now this
component is going to be colored blue
what's cool is I can change the color of
this from in this file so if I wanted to
make this like green for example I can
just pass in green and now the counter
is gonna be green so that's kind of how
you can use these components to make
your website more powerful and obviously
you can create more than just a counter
so I can create you know a couple of
dozen of these components and add them
in on my website like I could create a
component for like a navigation list I
can create a component for the header of
my website I could create a component
for a button really doesn't matter you
can create components for anything and
then you can sort of just use them on
your web pages in order to build your
user interface
in this tutorial I want to talk to you
about using plugins in Gatsby one of the
cool things about Gatsby is it allows
you to install and use external plugins
inside of your project and these
external plugins can do a bunch of cool
things they can add elements to your
website or they can make your website
more powerful so you definitely want to
consider using plugins if you're
building a Gatsby site I'm over here in
my web browser on this page right here
it's Gatsby j/s org forward slash Docs
four slash plugins this is sort of like
the official plugins page for Gatsby and
so if we just scroll down on this page
you'll see there's this huge list of
official Gatsby plugins that you can use
and a lot of these plugins were just
developed by Gatsby and there's also a
bunch of plugins that were developed by
the community and these plugins do you
know wide variety of things you know all
sorts of stuff and they can really just
make your website a lot more powerful so
what you should do is just kind of click
through these plugins and see if any
catch your eyes see if any you know you
might be useful on your website for
example here's one for Google Analytics
and for a lot of these plugins the ones
that are official plugins there's like a
they have their own page on Gatsby's
websites so you'll see like this plug-in
has its own page and there's like
installation instructions and it tells
you how to use them a lot of these
plugins will require like a little bit
of configuration to really get them
going and then a lot of these community
plugins will just link you to a github
page and you can you know same thing
just read the readme dot markdown file
and they give you the installation
instructions and stuff like that so I
want to talk to you in this video about
you know in downloading and installing
your own plugin and in this video we're
actually gonna install a plugin for
typography Jas and typography Jas is
like a CSS framework that we can use
inside of our website to kind of just
make it look better and style it a
little bit better by default so imagine
something like bootstrap
which you know styles your website
that's kind of like the plugin that
we're gonna be using so the way that you
install these plugins and the first
thing that you always have to do is
install the plug-in using the
node package manager so I'm just gonna
go down in my terminal and I'm just
gonna type out the following command I'm
just gonna type NPM installed - - save
and the plug-in that I'm gonna be
installing is this Gatsby plugin
typography and what this will do is
it'll install everything we need to run
that typography J ass on our Gatsby
website so I'm just gonna click enter
and no package manager will go out and
do its thing and get everything it needs
to run typography once that's finished
running and you get a success then
there's one more thing that we have to
do which is we basically just have to
tell Gatsby that we want to use that
plugin so we have to let Gatz me know
like hey we install this plugin and we
want to use it at our website the way we
can do that is by telling Gatsby inside
of this Gatsby config jas file now this
isn't a file that's going to be inside
of your directory by default and so you
want to create this file you want to
create this file at the root directory
of your site so in my case it would be
inside of this GA site folder so this
gatsby config file should be you know in
the same directory as the source folder
in the public folder inside of this
gatsby config dot JS file we want to
type a few things
the first thing we're just going to type
is module dot exports and this is going
to be equal to two curly brackets and
then inside of here I just want to make
an array so it's gonna be plugins and
inside of this plugins array we're just
gonna type out all the plugins that we
want to use so in my case I'm using the
Gatsby plug-in typography once you have
this in here basically this is just
telling Gatsby like hey we want to use
this plug-in and this Gatsby is gonna
read this config file every time it
builds your site so what we want to do
is just restart our website so restart
our web server and I just have it
running down here so I'm just gonna
gatsby develop and we'll restart our web
server and actually I think I
the module wrong yes that's why that's
not working so now that that's finished
running I want to go over to my website
and right here you'll notice that the
text has actually changed style so
before the text was like not really
styled very well and now it actually
looks pretty good and so what actually
happened was this
typography plugin got used by Gatsby and
it changed the way that our text looked
right so the typography is like a CSS
framework so it's changing the look in
the feel of our site and if I inspect
this page and I go up here in the head
of our website you'll see that there's
this new element here it's this style
tag and it says ID is typography j/s and
so actually what happened was got to be
used that typography plug-in to add this
typography code inside of our Gatsby
site so all we had to do was just
configure the plug-in and our website is
automatically styled with this cool
typography theme so you know what you
should do is go over to this plugins
website and play around with different
plugins you know see how they work on
your website see if you like them see if
you don't like them and you know just
basically use them to make your site
better any way that you can
in this tutorial I want to talk to you
about using the layouts in Gatsby
layouts are basically special types of
files that will act as a template for
all the pages on our website so imagine
there was a scenario where we were
creating a website and for every single
page on the website we wanted to have
like the same layout right so on every
page we wanted to have the same header
and we wanted to have the same footer
maybe we wanted to have like the same
navigational list and we wanted it to be
the same for all the pages on our
website now one way we could do that
would just be to copy and paste that
header or footer code onto every single
page and our website right so if we had
a hundred pages we would copy and paste
it a hundred times onto all of those
pages but a better way to do that would
be to just define some overall layout
for our site and then have all the pages
on our site and hair it from that layout
so all the pages on our site would use
that layout as their template or as
their skeleton of HTML code and then
they could just whatever a content is
inside that given page will just be
inserted inside that layout so I'm gonna
show you how to build layouts inside of
gatsby the way that we do that is by
first coming over to this source folder
and I want to create a new folder inside
of here and I'm just gonna call it
layouts and then inside of this layouts
folder we can create a new file and
we'll just call this index is an index
dot JSON
so in here I'm just gonna paste in some
code and I'll talk about what we have
here so I just have import react from
react and then export default and then
you need this parenthesis with curly
brackets inside and children and then
here we have the actual layout of our
website and so as long as you have
something that looks like this then you
should be able to implement this layout
now there's this special tag right here
it's children it's basically like a
children function that it's calling and
it's inside of these curly brackets and
what this will represent is the content
of the page that we're currently on so
just
demonstrate this I will type out some
text so we're gonna say lay out and
we'll say lay out and when I go over to
my website and actually before we do
that whenever you make a new layout you
need to restart your development server
so I'm gonna restart my Gatsby server
just like that and once that's done
restarting when i refresh this page
you'll notice that now instead of just
having a hello world and this is a
paragraph we have these layouts up here
and so layout is surrounding the content
of my page and I actually have a couple
other pages here I also have page two
and I have a page three so if I go over
to forward slash page - it's the same
thing so on this page - it's using the
same layout that our homepage used and
if I go to page three it's the same
thing so page three is also using this
layout so by default all the pages on
our website are gonna be using this
layout and these layouts are awesome
because over here for example I could
define like a header for my page and
this will just be a really simple header
and then I can also define like a footer
down here and that header in that footer
are gonna show up on every single page
inside of our website so this makes it
really easy to define a layout for all
the pages on your site so you could have
your header up here and your footer down
there and whenever you want change the
way that the header or the footer looks
you only have to change it right here on
this layouts page or on this index file
inside the layouts folder you don't have
to change it on any of the other pages
and that just makes your site more
modular and more scalable so play around
with these layouts and you know you can
basically just structure your whole site
inside of this layout and then all of
your content will just get injected into
the layout from this children function
in this tutorial I'm gonna talk to you
about using data and Gatsby and this is
just gonna be like a quick introduction
into how we can store some external data
about our website and then access that
data inside of our pages so imagine that
I wanted to store some information about
my site maybe I wanted to store like the
title of my website and the author of
the website and I wanted to be able to
access that information inside of
multiple pages on my site well one way I
could do that would be to just write out
that information at each one of my pages
so I could create a header in each page
and put in the site title right but
here's the problem if I want to then
change that title I would have to go
through to every single page on my site
and manually change the title I'd have
to do some sort of like a find/replace
and that could be really messy and it
could be potentially dangerous if not
everything is like spelled the same or
whatever an easier way would just be to
store the title of my website inside of
a variable somewhere and then have all
of my pages fetch that data and use that
variable right that way if I wanted to
change the title I would only have to
change it in one spot and it would
automatically update on all the pages in
my site so in this tutorial I'm gonna
show you how you can do something
exactly like that in Gatsby we want to
open up this gatsby config javascript
file and if you don't have this file
it's located at the root directory of
your project so in my case it's right
here in this GA site folder and if you
don't have it you can just create it so
this is basically like the main settings
configuration for our gatsby app so in
here you can put all sorts of important
things that will help gatsby to
configure itself and to just do what it
has to do so inside of this module dot
exports function and our object you want
to add this in we're gonna put a
attribute it's gonna be called site
metadata and this is going to be an
object and inside of this site metadata
object we can put any variables that we
want to access about our site so I could
put like title and we could give our
website a title so
say like traffic at amis website I could
also give this something maybe like an
author and we can just say the author's
me Mike so obviously this is just some
very simple data but I'm storing it
about my website now what I can do is I
can configure each one of my pages to go
out and grab this information and so my
pages will be able to display the
website title and the website author and
if I ever want to change those I only
have to change them in this config file
I don't have to touch the pages that are
pulling this data so I'm gonna head over
to one of my pages we'll just go to
index J s this is the home page and in
here what I want to do is make some
simple modifications which will allow me
to grab the data that is coming from
this gatsby config dot J's file so the
first thing I want to do is add what's
called a graph QL query and graph QL is
a querying language that was developed
by Facebook and it was designed to be
used with react and basically you can
use graph QL in order to grab
information from external sources in our
case we are grabbing information from
this gatsby config jas file so graph QL
is a querying language a lot like SQL if
you've ever used SQL before we can use
graph QL to write queries to get
information and that's what I'm gonna do
down here I actually have some code that
I'm gonna paste in here and then I'm
gonna explain what it does so this code
that I just pasted in is actually a
graph QL query and what this is doing is
it's going out to that config file and
it's grabbing the title and the author
so you can see it's just export Const
query is equal to graph QL and then we
have this single quote and then there's
another single quote down here and then
we have the query which is just the name
of the query up here and then we want to
grab information about the site and the
site metadata and the title and the
author so you what you want to do is
just paste this down into your file so
any files that you want
access the site metadata you want to
paste one of these graphed QL queries
into there and as long as you have this
graph QL query in here will actually be
able to access the information that's
inside the site metadata so once you
have this query inside of your file you
want to come up here and I'm here at
this export default and inside of these
parentheses you just want to put two
curly brackets and we're just going to
type out data and what this is gonna do
is it's gonna inject the data from this
query into our JSX and so now we can
actually access the data from the query
inside of our JSX code here so if i
wanted to do that i could just come over
here and we could actually print out
either the website title or the author
so why don't we do that inside of this
header one instead of saying hello world
why don't we print out the title of the
website so inside of some curly brackets
i'm just gonna type out data dot site
dot site metadata and then i want to
type out the name of the variable that I
want to access then even the attribute I
don't want to access so it's just gonna
be titled so if I save this page and
just a quick note whenever you modify
your Gadsby config file you have to
restart your gatsby development servers
and you can see that the text over here
is updated so now instead of saying
hello world it says draft Academy's
website and I can also access the author
so let's put the author down here in
this paragraph we'll just say and now we
should be able to see the author of the
page which is Mike so basically what we
did was we stored information about our
website some global variables inside of
this config gatsby file so we stored a
title and an author and then we were
able to access that title on that author
by running this graph QL query okay and
then that graph QL query grabbed the
data for us and injected it into our
react function here and then we're
able to access them inside of the JSX so
that's sort of the flow of the data
there's one more thing I want to show
you which is a really cool feature that
we can use with Gatsby which is called
graphed iql and graph iql is something
that i have open right here and the way
you access it is by going to localhost
8004 word slash three underscores and
then graph QL and you actually don't
need this query part right here and this
is a sort of a user interface a GUI for
testing out graph QL queries so inside
of here you could test out and write
different queries that you might be
writing obviously the query that we
wrote over here this is a pretty simple
query but if you have more complex
queries then you're gonna want to be
able to test them out so if I wanted to
I could actually test out a query here
so I can say like we could test out the
query that we're writing on this page so
I could say site and then site metadata
and then inside of here I could try to
access the title and the author and
you'll notice what I wrote here is
basically just what I have down here so
I'm testing out this query and then I
can run it and we'll see what returns
back so without actually putting this
inside my website I can test out the
query and make sure that I'm getting the
correct data back so this graft iql
feature of gatsby can be really useful
for helping you to test out your queries
and really just supercharging your
workflow
in this tutorial I want to talk to you
about using data in Gatsby now in the
last tutorial if you're following along
with the course we looked at grabbing
data about the site so inside of our
Gatsby config j/s file we had this site
metadata in here and we stored two
values about our website title and
author and then on this index dot JSP
we ran a graph QL query and then we were
able to access that information from
inside of our JSX
so over here we have this website that's
pulling the title of the website and
it's pulling the author of the website
this is a great way to use data and
store data about your website but it's
kind of limited right in other words
you're only able to pull the data that
you can store inside of this site
metadata object
so using gatsby we can actually access
other types of data and one type of data
that we can access is data about the
files in our website so one thing that
you might be curious if you're building
a website is what are the other pages
like how can we get information about
all of the pages on our site in this
tutorial I'm gonna show you exactly how
you can do that we'll be able to use
graph QL queries to figure out
information about the different pages on
our site therefore using that you can
build things like directories or you can
figure out you know what pages are in
what directories and what pages are
doing what it's really powerful so the
first thing that we want to do in order
to do something like that is we need to
install a Gatsby plug-in and this
plug-in is called Gatsby source file
system and basically what this plugin is
gonna do is it's gonna allow us to
access information about our file system
so I'm just gonna paste this in down
here into my terminal and you can go
ahead and copy this it's just npm
install - - save gatsby - source - file
system so we want to run that and we're
gonna let node package manager install
that on to our computer once that's
installed now we just have to tell
gatsby about it so i'm gonna come over
here into my godspeed config
jas file and inside of here I want to
create a new attribute in here and you
might already have something like this
but it's gonna be plugins and so it's
just gonna say plugins colon and then
this is gonna be an array and so this is
just an array of the different plugins
on our site
and I want to add in the plug-in that we
just installed so you want to put this
code in here and it's basically just
saying that we want to use the gatsby
source file system and then we're
passing it some different options so
we're passing it the name is source and
then we're passing it the directory name
forward slash source so this is
basically just telling gatsby where all
of the files on our website are located
and then it can go there and you know
figure out what we have available once
you update your Gatsby convict JS file
you want to restart your development
server so I'm just gonna do that and now
that this is restarted we can actually
start using this gatsby source file
system so I'm gonna come over here into
my web browser and I'm gonna open up
this graft ql' URL so it's localhost
colon 8080 thousand forward slash three
underscores and then graph QL and this
is called graph iql and it's basically
just a user interface for running graph
QL queries so we can test out graph QL
queries inside of here what I want to
type out is just open and close curly
brackets and if you type in like start
typing in a then you should see this all
file attribute should come up and if you
type in F you should see that file come
up comes up so this file in this all
file these both have to do with the sort
that with the plugin that we just
installed and so because we installed
that plug-in we're now able to see these
two guys so I'm just gonna click on all
file and then what you can actually do
is just click if you're on a Mac you can
click command enter if you're on Windows
you can click control enter and that's
gonna automatically fill out this query
for us and so you can see it's all file
edges node and then
right here we're looking at ID so right
now what we're doing is this query is
grabbing the ID of all the pages on our
website so if we look over here you can
see that it's pretty much doing that so
the ID is basically just the path so we
have this index J s file we have this
counter dot J's file we have this other
index j s file this page to file and
page 3 and those are all the pages that
I have over here on my website so this
is just looping through the file system
for my website and just printing it out
and in addition to printing out the ID
so you can print out ID here and you can
also print out a bunch of other stuff so
if you just click control-space
then this will give you an option for
it'll give you like a drop-down with all
the options so we could search for the
parent children pages internal source
instance name absolute path relative
path extension so why don't we search
for extension and we'll search for
relative path so this will give us the
extension of all the files and the
relative path of all the files and I'll
run this query and you can see that most
of these are like JS files and then we
have the relative paths for all the
pages so a query like this can be really
useful because not only does it allow us
to loop through all the pages on our
site but it allows us to access
different information about all the
pages on our site like you can see we
have all these things here so if you
were building like breadcrumbs
navigation for example you could use
this parent or this children attribute
in order to do that you can use these
absolute and relative paths to build
links so you can build like a table of
contents or something like that
so using these all file queries is a
really great way to and you know make
your website more powerful so I'm
actually going to give you a
demonstration of building something like
a navigation list I'm gonna go over here
to my index dot JSP and this is just
like the home page of my website and I'm
gonna be kind of pasting some different
code in here so you can just kind of
follow along with what I'm doing
sort of implement your own version of
this so the first thing I want to do is
just make sure that I have this data
attribute set up here so I want to pass
the data into my website and I'm just
going to get rid of these two guys and I
want to change up this query so right
now this query is accessing the title
and the author of the site metadata but
we want to change it up so we actually
want it to be the query that we're
similar to the query that we ran over
here and the query I'm gonna be using is
gonna look like this so I'm just gonna
paste this in and you can see it's just
what we did over there and that I grew
up in that graph QL but now we're
accessing relative path pretty sighs
extension and birth time so this will
give us some interesting information
about all the pages on our site and then
up here in our JSX we can actually grab
that information and use it so once
again I'm just gonna be pasting some
code in here and I'm gonna go ahead and
do that and basically what I tasted was
a table and this is just a basic sort of
JSX table up here I have the table head
and we have these table headers which
are basically just displaying all of
those attributes and then inside the
table I'm accessing all of these
attributes so I'm actually what I'm
doing is I'm looping through the results
of the all files query so that all files
query we look over here on the graph QL
you'll notice that it returned an array
so returned in an array of all the
different pages on our website so what
I'm doing over here is I'm looping
through all of the elements in that
array and I'm mapping them to basically
table rows so rolls row rows in the
table so each one of these like note
relative path each time through the loop
that's gonna represent a different
relative path of a different page on the
website so if I save this file and I
head back over here to my normal website
you'll notice that we have a table
that's just listing out all of the pages
and our website
and this isn't formatted perfectly but
you can you kind of get the idea right
it's giving the relative path of each of
the pages on our website the extension
how long ago it was made and then the
pretty size so basically like how big
the file is and this is just one example
of being able to loop through all of
these pages so when you're able to
access all this information about the
pages on your file system it really
makes it a lot easier to build out
certain navigational elements of your
website and also just to have
information about the different pages on
your website
in this tutorial I want to talk to you
about accessing markdown data in Gatsby
now if you've been following along with
this course you'll know that we've been
learning how to grab data and bring it
into our Gatsby files so I can go out
and I can grab information about the
Gatsby website and I can also get
information about the overall file
system that we're using so if you look
over here on this page right here I'm
basically have a table that's listing
out all of the pages that are inside of
my website but here's a question like
imagine that instead of just listing out
pages you actually wanted to access
information inside of those pages so
this is all information about the pages
right we have the relative path the size
the extension when it was created but
this isn't actually giving us it's only
giving us information about the page
it's not giving us like what's inside of
the page itself and if you're trying to
build like a blog or something and
especially if you're trying to work with
markdown you're gonna want to be able to
access more information about the page
you're gonna want to be able to like
figure out okay what information is
actually inside of these markdown files
that I'm creating and be able to use
that information to display those pages
better so in order to do that we need to
actually install another plugin and
before I install the plug-in I just want
to make a new markdown file so inside of
my pages directory I'm just gonna make a
markdown file called my first post and
this will just sort of represent like a
markdown file post that we can access
and inside of this post I want to start
by writing something called front matter
and frontmatter is basically information
that you can write about the different
pages or the different markdown pages on
your website so up here in between these
three dashes I can actually write some
variables so I could define a title and
we can just say that this is like my and
then I could also define something else
like an author so I can you know define
like who's writing this or get to say to
me so this is called frontmatter and
this is basically just data that you're
defining a
the data in this file so it's metadata
and then we can just put some content so
this is the content in my markdown so
what I want to be able to do is run a
query to be able to access this markdown
and first thing I'll point out is if you
notice over here the table that we're
looking at here is actually updated and
so now it's including my first post out
markdown and over here I'm using the
source file system plug-in in order to
display this stuff and so automatically
when I create this new markdown file it
gets added into our table here but
instead of just being able to figure out
that we have a markdown file I actually
want to be able to access the
information inside of this file so I
want to be able to access the actual
markdown content right here and then I
want to be able to access these
frontmatter variables up here and if I
can do that then I can create a listing
on my page that will list out all of
these files or all of these markdown
files and the way that I do that is
opening up my terminal and I actually
want to install something and this is
gonna be a nother Gatsby plugin and I'm
just gonna paste this down here and
you'll notice it's just NPM install - -
save gatsby transformer remark so this
is gonna be a plug-in that's gonna allow
us to do some stuff with those markdown
files so I'm just gonna click enter and
NPM is gonna go off and do its thing and
once that's done running we can actually
go over to our Gatsby config file and
tell gatsby that we want to use it so
over in this gatsby config file down
here inside of this plugins array I'm
just gonna add another entry and we're
just gonna type out the name of the
plug-in that we just downloaded so it's
just gonna be gatsby transform or remark
just like that so once we have that in
here I just want to restart my gatsby
development server and now that this is
running I want to head over to this
graph iql user interface and we can
start trying to access the information
in this markdown file since you just
added that new plugin we
now have access to a couple new
attributes inside of this graph QL and
you want to just start typing out all
and what you should see is all markdown
remark and you can also just start
typing markdown and you'll see that
these two new options have appeared so
markdown remark and all markdown remark
and these are now things that we can use
to query the markdown files in our file
system so I'm just gonna do all markdown
remark and I'm just going to click ctrl
enter or command enter and this will
start up a default query for us so this
is just going to query through all of
the markdown files on our site so if I
play this query you'll notice over here
we have the basically like the ID of the
path so it's just pages my first post
dot markdown and if I added in some
other markdown files then more entries
would show up here so let's do that
let's add another markdown file we'll
just call it markdown too I can give
this some frontmatter as well so we'll
just give this a title
so over here now when I replay this the
new markdown file should show up and so
here we have that markdown to file
showing up in addition to just accessing
the ID there's also a lot of other
things we can access so if you click
control space then this list is gonna
pop up and this will give you everything
that you can access about the markdown
file so one cool thing is this HTML
right here and this HTML will basically
just spit out the actual HTML of the
markdown file so you can use this HTML
attribute in order to insert the content
of the markdown file into one of your
web pages we can also access that
information that was inside of the
frontmatter so if I just type out
frontmatter
you'll notice by default it's China
query for date and parent but since we
only have title we want to just query
for the title and you'll notice that
it's giving us the title of both of
these from matter or both of these
markdown pages so you can use these
markdown queries in order to access
information about the markdown files
that are in your site hey thanks for
watching if you enjoyed the video please
leave a like and subscribe